On Monday we presented,
I presented an introduction to evolutionary psychology to looking at psychology
from evolutionary perspective and trying to make a case and give some examples
of how it can help illuminate and illustrate certain aspects of how the mind
works.
One of the advantages of an evolutionary perspective on the mind is that it
forces us to,
um,
to look scientifically at what we were otherwise take for granted.
There are a lot of aspects of how we are and what we are and what we do that
seems so natural to us.
They come so instinctively and easily.
It's difficult and sort of unnatural to step back and explore them
scientifically.
Um,
but if we're going to be scientists and look at the mind from a scientific
perspective,
we have to get this sort of distance from ourselves and ask questions that other
people would not normally think to ask.
And the clearest case of this,
um,
arises with the emotions.
And as a starting point,
uh,
there's a lovely quote from the psychologist and philosopher William James,
I didn't want to begin with.
So he writes to the psychologist alone,
can such questions occur as,
why do we smile when please did not scour?
Why are we unable to talk to a crowd as we talked to a single friend,
why does a particular maiden turn our wits upside down?
The common man,
none of you are the common man.
The common man can only say,
of course we smile.
Of course,
our heart palpitates at the site of the crowd.
we love the maiden and so probably does each animal feel a bit of taking their
things.
It tends to do in the presence of certain objects to the lion.
It is the lioness which is made to be loved to the beer,
the she bear to the broody.
Hen.
The notion would probably see monsters that there should be a creature in the
world whom a nest full of eggs was not the utterly fascinating and precious and
never to be too much sat upon object,
which it is to her.
Now,
there's a few things to note about this passage.
First,
it's incredibly sexist.
It assumes a not just merely in reflective use of phrases.
It assumes that William James,
as soon as he's talking to,
to,
uh,
males,
male humans who sometimes take the perspective of male bears and,
um,
and,
and so it assumes a male audience.
You wouldn't normally,
you wouldn't actually ever write this way.
Um,
a second point is it's beautifully written and you're not awesome.
I allowed to write that way anymore either.
Um,
it's poetic and lyrical.
And if a William James Characteristically writes that way,
um,
I think he writes so much better than his brother Henry James and obscure
novelist.
Um,
finally though,
the point that he makes is a terrific one,
which is,
yes,
all of these things seem natural to us,
but the reason why they seem natural is not because they are in some sense
necessary or logical truth.
Rather,
they emerged from contingent aspects of our biological nature.
Um,
and so we need to step back.
We actually,
we need to step back and ask questions like,
and these are questions we're gonna ask.
Um,
why does poop smell bad?
Avoid the temptation to say,
well,
poop smells bad because it's so stinky.
This thinking is of poop is not an irreducible factor,
but the universe rather,
the sneakiness of poop is a fact about human psychology to a dung beetle.
Poop smells just fine.
Why does chocolate tastes good?
Well,
chocolate,
the ta,
the good tastiness of chocolate isn't some necessary fact about the world.
It's a fact of our minds that doesn't hold true for many other creatures.
And so we have to step back and ask why to us do we find chocolate appealing?
Why do we love our children?
Don't say they're lovable.
Many of them are not.
And,
and,
and as William James points out,
every animal,
most animals,
many animals love their children.
They think their children are precious and wonderful.
Why?
Um,
why do we get angry when people hit us?
Suppose somebody walked up to you and slap you in the face.
You'd be afraid you'd be angry.
Would you?
Would you get sleepy?
You feel,
feel nostalgic,
suddenly desire some cold soup?
No.
Those are stupid alternatives.
Of course,
if somebody slapped us,
you would,
we would get angry or afraid.
Why?
Um,
why do we feel good when someone does us a favor?
Why don't we feel angry?
Why don't we feel fearful?
What we're going to do throughout this course is step back and ask these
questions.
We're gonna ask questions nobody would have otherwise thought to ask where the
common man,
um,
wouldn't address.
And this is of course,
standard in all the sciences.
Um,
the,
the first step to insight is to ask questions like why do the things fall down
and not up?
And I imagine the first person who articulated the question aloud probably met
with the response saying,
what a stupid question.
Of course things fall down.
Oh yes,
of course things fall down,
but why?
Um,
why is our flesh warm?
Why does water turned solid when it gets cold?
These are natural facts about the universe,
but the naturalness needs to be explained and not merely assumed.
In this class,
we're going to explore throughout course what seems natural to us and try to
make sense of it and to that.
And to that end,
we have to ask questions that you wouldn't normally ask.
We've already done this to some extent with domains such as visual perception,
memory,
language and rationality.
But now we're going to move to the case where it's maybe even somewhat more
difficult to do this.
And I want to start dealing with their emotions.
Um,
we're going to talk about their emotions,
why they exist,
what they're there for,
and how they work.
I want to start off with the wrong theory of emotions.
And the wrong theory of the emotions is beautifully illustrated in a television
and movie series,
Star Trek.
Um,
in,
in this alternatives fantasy world,
there are characters,
um,
ms Mr Spock and original star trek data in one of the spinoffs who are described
as competent,
capable.
In fact,
many ways super competent and super capable people,
but they're described as not having emotions.
Spock is described as not having emotion cause he's half Vulcan from a planet
where they lack emotions.
Um,
data is an android who has said to lack an emotion chip.
This lack of emotions on us,
on a TV series does not hurt them much.
They're able to fully function.
And in fact,
in a TV series,
um,
emotions are often seen as a detriment.
You do better off without them.
And there are many people in sort of common sense might think,
Gee,
if only I could just use my rationality,
think reasonably and rationally and not let my emotions guide my behavior,
I'd be much better off.
It turns out that this is a notion of how to think about the emotions that is
deeply wrong and in fact makes no sense at all.
I'm using the example of Star Trek Steven pinker in his book,
how the mind works nicely illustrates the problem here.
He writes,
spark must've been driven by some motives or goals.
Something must have led him to explore strange new worlds,
to seek out new civilizations and to boldly go where no man had gone before.
Presumably it was intellectual curiosity that set them to drive and solve
problems.
Um,
it was,
um,
solidarity with his allies that,
that led him to be such a competent and brave officer.
What would he have done if attacked by a Predator or an invading clean on?
Did he do a handstand,
solved a four color map theorem,
presumably a part of his brain,
quickly mobilized his faculties to scope out how to flee and had to take steps
to avoid the vulnerable predicament in the future.
That is,
he had fear.
Swath did not walk around naked around the ship.
Presumably he felt modesty.
He got out of bed,
presumably he had some ambitions and drive.
He engaged in conversations presumably at some social interests without emotions
to drive us.
We would do nothing at all.
And you could illustrate this scientifically.
Creatures like swack and data don't exist in the real world,
but there are unusual and unfortunate cases where people lose to some extent or
another,
their emotions and you could look at these people and see what happens to them.
The classic case,
the most famous case is that of a man called Phineas gage.
Phineas gage is the classic intro psych example.
Extremely poor guy portion.
Um,
in 1848,
he was a construction foreman.
In 1848 he was working at a site with explosion explosives and iron rods and due
to an explosion,
an iron rod pass through his head like so imagine that rod shooting upwards.
It went under his eye and popped out the top of his head.
It landed about a hundred feet away,
covered with blood and brains.
The rod itself weighed 13 pounds.
Um,
amazingly gage was not killed.
In fact,
he was knocked unconscious only for a short period.
And then he got up and his friends surrounded him and asked,
are you okay?
And they,
uh,
and then they took him to the hospital on the way that a hospital,
they stopped by a tavern and he had a little pint of cider drink,
sat down to talk to people.
And um,
and then he had,
he had an infection,
had to have surgery,
but when it's all said and done,
he wasn't blind.
He wasn't deaf,
didn't lose language and become APHASIC,
no paralysis,
no retardation
in some sense.
What happened was much worse.
He,
um,
he lost his character.
Here's a description at the time of what gauge was like.
And this is from Damasio's.
Excellent book,
Descartes' error.
Um,
used to be a really responsible guy,
a family man,
very reliable,
very trustworthy.
But after the accident he was fitful,
irreverent,
indulging at times and a gross is profanity manifesting,
but little deference for his fellows.
Impatient of restraint or advice.
Um,
a child in his intellectual capacities and manifestations.
He had an animal pleasures of a strong man.
His foul language is so debased that women are advised not to stay long in his
presence.
Um,
and he couldn't hold a job.
He lost his family,
couldn't hold a job.
He ended up in the circus.
He was in a circus going around the country with his big iron rod,
telling everybody the story as they surrounded in clap.
Um,
there are other cases,
like Phineas gage cases where people have had damage to that same part of the
brain,
parts of the,
of the frontal cortex.
Um,
and what they've lost is they basically lost a good part of their emotions.
And what this means is they don't really care that much about things.
They can't prioritize.
Dimassio tells a case of one of his patients who were,
who was under the pseudo name here of Elliot and Elliot had a tumor in his
frontal lobe and the tumor had to be removed.
And with it came a lot of Elliot's frontal lobe.
And again,
as a result of this,
Elliot was not struck blind or deaf or retarded and he didn't become the sort of
profane character that Phineas gage became.
But he,
um,
he lost the ability to prioritize.
He lost the ability to set goals.
Damasio describes him here,
um,
at his job,
at an activity he would read and fully understand the significance and the
material.
He works in an office.
Um,
but the problem was he was likely all of a sudden to turn from your task.
He had initiated to doing something else and spending an entire day doing that.
He might spend an entire afternoon deliberating on which principal of
categorization he should apply to files,
should it be the day or the size of the document pertinent to the case or
another.
He couldn't set his goals.
He couldn't,
he ended up not being able to keep a job,
not being able to deal with people.
And these are not men who have lost her emotions.
There is no case around,
we could tie,
have your emotions entirely blotted out,
but they lost a large part of their emotional capacity.
And as a result,
their rationality failed emotion,
set goals and establish priorities.
And with Elac Numb,
you wouldn't do anything.
You couldn't do anything.
You desire to come to class,
to study,
to go out with friends,
to read a book,
to,
to raise a family,
to be,
to do anything.
Our priorities set by your emotions.
Life would be impossible without those emotions.
Um,
and so there's a certain themes we're going to explore here.
The first is this,
that emotions are basically mechanisms that set goals and priorities.
And when a talk a lot about in this class and next class about universals,
um,
we're also going to talk about culture.
It turns out that culture is different cultures including differences between
America in Japan and the American south in American north have somewhat
different emotional triggers and emotional baselines to respond to.
But at the same time as Darwin,
well new emotions have universal routes that are shared across all humans and
across many animals.
So the agenda for this class and next class is going to go like this.
First I want to talk a little bit about facial expressions,
which are ways in which we communicate our emotions,
not the only way.
What an important way and look in particular at the case of smiling cause it's
kind of interesting.
Then I want to look at one case study of a non social emotion.
That of fear.
I wanted them deal with feelings towards our kin.
People were genetically related to and then,
and this will take us to next class,
feelings towards non Kim.
Okay.
So first faces and as an introduction to face is I have a brief film clip from
Paul Ekman who's one of the world's great scholars in the study of facial
expressions
and that Cummins work.
He presents us with instructions
on how to make different faces and identify faces.
Ekman actually has a sort of more practical career long for scientific career.
He trains police and secret service members to them too.
I did to try to figure out cues to honesty and dishonesty.
It was a very interesting New Yorker profile on him by Malcolm Gladwell a few
years ago.
Some of you may be interested in,
but um,
let's do one of his faces.
Okay.
Please lower your brows and draw them together.
Yeah,
that means even those who aren't making eye contact with me,
hence your lower and upper eyelids don't pop out contact lenses,
but just to them
stare your eyes can bold somewhat.
Okay.
Now,
last part important.
Press your lips together.
The corner.
Straight or down.
That's good.
You got it.
Okay.
Cause you're making,
not making eye contact with me doesn't mean I can't see you.
Okay.
Well what you're looking like presumably as this and um,
and what,
what face is that,
what emotion does that correspond to?
Anger.
Um,
there's all sorts of databases of different phases from around this guy.
I don't know who he is,
but he seems to be on,
on a lot of these things.
Um,
but,
but the thing is you don't,
um,
you don't need to,
uh,
you don't need to rely on him.
You don't need to rely on Western faces.
Even if you go online,
there's by now a lot of databases from faces,
from all sorts of genders and a national origins.
This is from a Japanese,
Japanese women facial expressions.
And there are some subtle and very interesting differences across countries and
across people,
but there's also deep universals.
Um,
you don't have to work very hard to figure out what these different facial
expressions mean.
I want to give one more face example cause I want to focus on this a little bit.
Um,
this one's a little bit easier.
Raise the corners of your lips back and I please
raise your cheeks.
Raise your lower eyelids if you can.
The smiling,
you're smiling,
you can stop
smiling.
Yale is actually really big on smiling.
Um,
we have two of the world's experts on smiling.
this is,
uh,
this is the Angus Trumbull.
I'm the curator at the British art gallery,
um,
who wrote this wonderful book,
a brief history of the smile,
um,
looking at a smile and art.
And this is my colleague,
Maryann La France who was actually not smiling in that picture,
but um,
but she studies smiling and smiling and adult smiling children smiling across
cultures and the different social uses of smiling.
And there's some interesting discoveries people have made about smiles and about
smiles and emotions.
Uh,
one oh well one is that smiles are,
um,
are universal.
We,
um,
we know for instance,
that young children smile.
This is,
uh,
this is my son accurate when he was younger.
Not,
not that we're looking at.
Thank you.
Thank God.
And,
um,
and even um,
even blind,
even blind children,
children blind from birth will smile.
They'll smile appropriately.
Making an important point.
This smiling has not learned by looking at other people's faces.
Smiling is also not uniquely human.
Nonhuman primates smile as well.
Smiles are social signals.
You might imagine that people smile when they're happy.
This is actually not the case.
It's not as simple as that.
Rather people smile when they wish to communicate happiness.
And we know that from several studies.
Um,
there's some studies of boulders and the studies are very nice.
What they do is they film bowler sort of boulders,
do their bowling and sometimes they knocked down all the pins,
which is called a what?
A strike.
So strict and that's good in the bowling world.
Um,
so they knocked down all the pins,
but what they don't do is they don't smile after you knocked down to pence.
They're being filmed.
They don't then they turn around to their friends and give a big grant.
Other studies have looked at films of people who have just won Olympic gold
medals.
Now,
not surprisingly,
uh,
people who want Olympic gold medals are very happy.
This is good news to win an Olympic gold medal,
but they don't actually stand on the podium like grinning.
Rather they stand there,
put your faces and normal expression.
Then when they stand up and face the crowds,
there's a big smile.
Um,
you can ask yourself whether during sex and activity where many people enjoy,
um,
whether or not people smile during sex.
And you can discover this yourself with
partner or a mirror.
Um,
so,
or other things we know about smiles,
um,
there are different types of smiles.
They're actually quite a few different types of smiles that are different in
interesting ways.
Um,
this is Paul Ekman again,
which one's a hat?
Which one's a better smile?
Who votes for the 100?
Right?
Who will votes for one on the left?
There are two different sorts of smiles.
Um,
the one on the right is a smile of greeting.
It's sometimes known as a Pan Am smile.
Pan Am is a now defunct airline,
um,
which had at that time they weren't,
you don't call them stewardesses anymore,
but the stewardess,
this would come in and they would smile.
That was part of your job,
but it was a big fake smile.
The Pan Am's smile,
a smile to communicate hello.
And but it's as opposed to a smile where the communication is that of genuine
happiness.
The differences around the eyes.
It's not the mouth,
it's the eyes.
Um,
I real happiness,
smile.
What's known as a Duchenne smile after a neurophysiologist who studied it
involves moving the eyes.
What's interesting is about only one out of every 10 people can fake a Duchenne
smile.
So if you smile at somebody and you just hate their guts,
but you want to smile at them,
um,
it's unless you're quite gifted,
it's difficult to fake a really good,
really happy smile.
Um,
you could say it's,
it's not difficult to study smiles in the real world.
Um,
you can look at politicians for instance.
politicians are often in context where they have to smile lot.
Um,
and what they do is they simply give the Pan Am smile,
the mouth moves up.
Particularly if somebody is,
you know,
it's hacking or record our are ridiculing know,
and they'll smile and,
but it's not as sincere smile.
The eyes don't move.
My favorite example of this was a few years ago when there was a huge battle for
the house,
the House majority leader and a guy named a Republican named John Bonner one.
This position,
I'm in quite a heated battle and it took a picture of the guy.
This is not very nice there.
The visual guy,
Roy Blunt,
as he stepped out and he had lost and this was his expression
and you know,
he's not really very happy
as opposed to a smile like this,
which is a real smile.
So,
so you have two sorts of smiles that are real happiness,
smile and,
and,
and a Duchenne smile called also known as the Duchenne smile.
And then,
um,
uh,
Pan Am's smile or greeting smile.
And you'll use each of those smiles at different points in your day,
in your life.
It turns out the DS,
the DS,
different smiles have real psychological validity.
They seem to sort of reflect deep differences in your mood and emotions and Fox,
um,
10 month olds for instance,
give different sorts of smiles.
Um,
when their mother approaches there,
they give a real happiness smile.
Then when a stranger approaches or someone else approaches there,
it will tend to give more of a greeting smile.
Uh,
John Gottman studied married couples and John Gottman does a lot of work where
what he does is he looks at film and clips of couples and by analyzing the film
clips,
he tries to predict,
well their marriages survive.
And one of his cues,
there's different queues incidentally,
sort of side topic.
Um,
did the death knell for a marriage for Gottman,
this is his big finding.
It's not if they fight a lot,
it's not a scream at each other.
It's not even if they hate each other,
the death knell of a marriage is contempt.
And so if he,
if he shows these clips,
you know,
I walk in honey,
I'm home and my spouse goes,
the look of contempt.
It's bad sign.
But another clue is the sort of smiles they give when they see each other when
they walk into the lab.
If it's a true happiness smile,
that's actually bodes better for,
um,
the relationship then a pan am or greeting smile.
Finally,
studies haven't been done at college yearbook photos,
looking at people.
I'm 30 years later.
And it turns out that there's a correlation,
a reliable relationship between how happy somebody is now and back 30 years ago
near Yearbook photo.
What sort of smile they're giving.
There's some evidence for a third sort of smile.
This is known as a coy smile or an appeasement smile.
Um,
this is sort of a very specialized sort of smile.
This is a smile.
Um,
I've embarrassment or stress you give it when,
um,
when,
when you want people to like you,
you want to join him,
you want to make people feel positive about you,
but you were in sort of a high stress situation often with some sort of risk.
And what you do is you sort of,
you sort of,
uh,
you,
you turn away,
there's no eye contact.
You turn away and kind of give this,
and this actually shows up in other primates.
Here's a nice picture.
Um,
so the reason is Munkee bites her own infant and infant gives a screen and then
this submissive Koi smile.
Um,
and it also shows up in human infants.
Here's a nice clip of a Koi baby smile.
Walk you through it.
Um,
the baby,
um,
being approached.
I was like this and then the version.
Yeah.
Babies are babies are cute.
Um,
any questions at this point about smiling?
Yeah.
What are your smiling questions?
Yeah,
it's a good question.
I don't know.
There's evidence that the Koi smile shows up in non,
the question was do nonhuman primates give the same,
the same smiles that humans do,
such as the distinction between,
um,
the Pan Am smile,
a greeting smile versus a genuine smile of happiness?
I don't know.
I'll find out for you for next class though.
That's a good question.
Yeah,
come.
Some people smiles are better than other people's smiles.
How come some people smiles are better than other people's smiles?
Um,
you know,
the non interesting psychological answers.
Some people are better looking and there's more,
more thing but,
but,
but the deeper answer is some people are,
um,
are better able to smile.
Some people are better able to use the cues to express true happiness.
There's something else about smiles which is going to come up with what's your
question?
Raises,
I think,
which is gonna come up in when we talk about emotional contagion and asking you
some issues of morality.
Smiles are extremely contagious.
So what I'd like people to do,
if you're sitting next to somebody,
please,
please turn around and find someone next to you and look at them.
Don't do anything.
Just look at them.
Look at them.
Whoever's being looked at,
looked back.
This is not.
Please,
please arbitrarily decide,
okay.
Please arbitrarily decide on the smiler that will be no,
not at me.
At each other.
Yeah.
MMM.
And that will be the person.
If you are,
if you are unable to resolve this dispute,
yes,
you too.
Please.
If you aren't able to resolve this dispute,
the person to the right of me will be a smiler.
So look at each other.
Expressionless
now the person who's the mandated smiler on three,
please smile.
One,
two,
three.
Okay.
Worst class demo ever.
Um,
but
if one could imagine more restraints,
circumstances,
it is actually extremely difficult to,
um,
to be facing somebody who's really smiling at you and not smile.
This is true,
by the way,
for virtually every other emotions.
The phenomena is known as emotional contagion where if you're facing somebody
for instance and there they look at you in a phase of absolute rage,
it is very difficult to just sit there about your own face molding in a core to
their own and the reasons why this happens and how that works.
It's something we'll talk about later on.
So that's
one more question.
Yes.
People smiling in their teeth.
I don't know if that's the question is is there a devotee smiling like with your
t uh,
versus just your lips closed?
Um,
there probably is.
That's not a main smile difference,
but my bet is that there probably is a difference.
And my bet also is that that sort of distinction,
how much teeth you show when you smile is the sort of thing that will feel
regional and country by country differences.
For instance,
there's been research finding that people in England smile different from people
in the United States.
And I think that those are the sort of contrast that you would expect to find
cross cultural differences.
Every culture is going to have Pan Am's smiles,
happiness,
smiles,
coy smiles.
But the variation of that sort,
it's something which will vary,
uh,
as a result of how you're raised and the people around you.
I want to deal with a few emotions in this class and next.
And,
um,
the first case study of an emotion I want to deal with is the emotion of fear.
And I want to deal with fear for different reasons.
One reason is it's a basic emotion.
It's universal.
All humans habit,
many nonhumans probably most nonhuman species habit too.
And it also brings us back to the lecture on behaviors and where we talked about
classical conditioning and different theories of what people are afraid of.
Um,
it's a non social emotion.
What I mean by this is it's possible of course to be afraid of a person,
but unlike an emotion like gratitude,
it's not intrinsically social.
You could be afraid of falling off a cliff or something.
Um,
it has a distinctive facial expression.
Again,
this is,
um,
uh,
a famous picture of Lee Harvey Oswald,
who's being assassinated by Jack Ruby.
And this is the detectives face standing there,
a mixture of fear and anger.
The face being drawn back in a universal expression that every human everywhere
would be able to recognize.
So the basic question to ask is,
what are we afraid of?
And the answer's a little bit interesting.
We're afraid of spiders,
snakes,
heights,
storms,
large animals,
darkness,
blood,
strangers,
humiliation,
deep water and the living leaving home alone.
And you afraid of other things too.
But those are big things to be afraid of.
I'm not even going to ask you if there's somebody who in this room who's not
afraid of any of those things.
You're a tougher person than I am.
I mean,
these are universal fear or listeners,
why,
what do they have in common?
Why would you be afraid of those things?
And the answer is,
and why would,
why are there so few people are afraid of guns,
cars,
and electrical outlets.
Um,
the answer is not particularly surprising.
these are things that makes ticking over there.
These are things that are scary in our ancestral environment.
More particularly.
These are things that through the course of human evolution have been dangerous
to us.
And so we're afraid of these things.
And not so afraid of these things.
Similarly for nonhuman primates.
So chimpanzees are afraid of certain things and they could often develop phobias
for certain things,
but the phobias,
they developed a fear as they develop or things like spiders and snakes.
Um,
there was a nice study done in urban Chicago,
in the inner city of Chicago and they asked children,
raised in inner city,
what are you most afraid of?
And you might think they would say,
I'm afraid of being shot.
I'm afraid of guns,
I'm afraid of,
of,
of um,
being killed by somebody being harmed by sir.
I'm afraid to be run over by a car.
The two biggest fears of children urban Chicago are
okay
that snakes and spiders,
even though many of these children had probably never seen a snake outside of a
zoo in their lives.
These are natural fears.
There's some research done by the psychologist Judy Dillo to University of
Virginia where she studying babies fears of spiders and snakes.
Um,
babies obviously who since their parents are normal,
I have not yet seen spiders and snakes for.
There are various ethical reasons why you can't a show babies.
You can't try to construct phobias in babies of spiders and snakes.
But the research is finding using more indirect methods,
fines as one would expect.
These are what psychologists would call pre potent stimuli.
That is,
these are things that naturally elicit fear and concern.
And that's all I have to say about fear.
Okay.
I want to turn for the rest of this lecture and for next lecture next week to
the social emotions and the social emotions can be broken down into two
categories.
Bless you,
bless you.
Um,
those emotions you feel towards your 10,
towards your genetic relatives and those emotions that you feel towards the
people you're not related to but interact with.
Um,
and
I want to focus particularly on emotions that generate kind or altruistic
behavior.
Altruism is the biologist term meaning kindness,
generosity and evolutionary biologists have worked really hard to explain why
animals might evolve to be kind.
A very old,
very wrong view of evolution is that evolution has shaped animals such that
they're merely survival machines.
If so,
then from an evolutionary standpoint,
any kindness towards an animal than an animal shows towards another animal is a
mystery.
If evolution wired us up simply to survive,
then um,
then it's a puzzle.
Why animals would relate,
would relate positively to other animals.
But of course that's not true.
Um,
here's a simple example showing it's not true.
Imagine two genes,
two sorts of animals.
Each containing their own gene.
Gna makes an animal care for its offspring.
Gene B makes an animal care only for itself.
Imagine what will happen in the next generation.
Plainly,
GNA will win out.
It's a very simple case.
An animal who has evolved the brain that says,
take care of your offspring will do much better from a natural selection point
view from an animal who has evolved the brain that says,
eat your offspring.
The animal that eats its offspring,
those genes are biological,
dead end.
Um,
what matters then is not survival per se.
What matters is reproduction.
And so that simple fact is why we would explore,
expect animals to care for their children because children are the means through
which genes replicate.
But against a little bit richer than that.
And this is one of the major revolutions in evolutionary biology over the last
half century.
Forget about the animal a bit and take another perspective.
Take a perspective of the cold virus.
People have been sneezing in the front row.
Now you're coughing.
Thank you.
Um,
why do you sneeze when you get a cold?
Here's not a
point made.
Um,
here's,
here's not a bad answer.
You sleeves because you got all these germs inside you and your body wants to
get their germs out so you sneeze.
Um,
it's not that it's totally wrong,
but it's not,
it's not bad.
The real answer is a little bit more interesting.
Don't look at it from the person's perspective.
If you have a cold,
try to get away from your own selfish perspective.
I have a cold look at it from the perspective of the cold virus.
The cold virus has evolved just as much as you evolved and it's evolved due to
survival.
And reproduction.
Um,
what the coal virus does is it's evolved different strategies to cause it to
reproduce.
And what it does is one way to reproduce is to,
is to occupy other animals and manipulate their bodies so as to expel it from
this point of view.
Then the reason why you sneeze when you have a coal is that your cold virus,
the cold virus,
is using your body as a tool to replicate itself from this person.
This perspective,
a person is just the germs way of making other germs.
And there's tons of other examples of this.
There's a,
there's a parasite known as toxoplasmosis that lives into bodies of rats,
but it gets passed on when the rats get eaten by hats and an ends up in a cat's
feces and then ends up back in rats.
Um,
if you are a rat and you have toxoplasmosis,
you are perfectly healthy except for one thing.
The toxoplasmosis rewires your brain and it makes you less afraid of cats.
Now again,
this is not some sort of bizarre quirk of a humorous God.
Rather,
it's because this is a perfectly,
this is the adaptive strategy of Dipak toxoplasmosis virus.
Um,
in fact,
a real powerful virus would skip the respiratory system altogether even better
than a cold virus.
What it would do is it would take over the brain and it will make people want to
run around and have sex with other people and kissing him on the mouth.
Um,
and in fact,
there's some evidence that this happens.
There's some evidence,
for instance,
that one of the effects of sexually transmitted diseases like syphilis is it
arouses the libido,
makes people more sexually engaged because this is part of the strategy through
which these viruses replicate what themselves.
Imagine a virus,
for instance,
that captured an animal's brain and then modify the animal's brain such that the
animal run out and bite other animals so as to pass on the virus.
And then of course,
you would call that virus.
Rabies.
Along these lines,
the evolutionary biologist Richard Dawkins took the general step of suggesting
the animals are the vehicles through which genes exploit to reproduce.
From this perspective,
I'm an animal is just the person's,
is,
is just the gene's way of creating another animal.
Well,
as psychologists,
what benefit does that does this way of analysis gives us,
it actually can help us explain altruism.
So which genes are going to survive?
Well,
the Jesus,
if I was going to be the ones that make the most copies of themselves,
animals or vehicles through which genes reproduce an animals merely to gene's
way of making another gene,
hence selfish genes will lead to out heuristic animals.
Because to the extent that evolution operates at a level of the genes,
there's no hard and fast distinction between your own body and someone else's
body.
Um,
and here's an illustration by the biologist Haldane.
So Haldane was once asked,
would you lay down your life for your brother?
And he responded,
no,
but I would gladly give my life for three brothers or five nephews or nine first
cousins.
Now
he's joking.
You don't actually do the math if you're normal,
but,
but when he's capturing is the logic,
the ultimate causation of our feelings towards our kin.
Um,
our genes,
I've wired us up our brains up to love our children and love our Ken.
Um,
because in this way,
our genes managed to replicate themselves.
And in fact,
you get his calculations by looking at genetic relatedness to genetic
relatedness from an evolutionary standpoint affects how much you care for other
people from the standpoint of your genes.
You dying for the life of three brothers is an excellent compromise because the
genes replicate by 50% more.
Um,
if you imagined.
So here's this calculations.
If you imagined a choice between or is one gene that makes the animal choose to
die and the other gene that makes an animal choose for his brothers to die,
the gene that sacrifices the body it belongs to,
we'll make more copies in the future.
And there's an interesting irony to this.
Um,
the selfish gene theory is often seen as sort of a coldblooded evolutionary
analysis,
but it provides a scientific basis for real,
genuine altruism for really arguing that from the standpoint of the genes,
there really is no hard and fast difference between yourself and another person.
From this perspective,
we can start to answer some interesting questions,
uh,
at least about nonhumans.
Um,
when a new male lion takes over a pride,
what he does is kill older remaining cubs and any lionesses undergo spontaneous
abortions.
This all might seem very cruel,
but from a genetic standpoint,
it makes sense.
Um,
the other cubs,
our genetic competition for him,
they do not have his genes.
Um,
moreover,
um,
only once they're out of the way can they reproduce and copulate with the
females,
the females do neuro spontaneous abortions because that's a reliable adaptive
trick.
These cubs are not going to survive once they're born.
So the females best strategies to get rid of them and start a new
from a psychological point,
then animals have evolved to be nice to their kin,
particularly their children.
And particularly in birds and mammals.
Birds and mammals invest in quality and not quantity as opposed to fishing and
reptiles.
For birds and mammals,
we don't have many kids.
Um,
but so we,
we devote a huge amount of psychological energy to,
um,
to protecting the ones that we have.
Moreover,
the kids we have are vulnerable for long periods of time and require our
resources.
So there was various psychological mechanisms that this gives rise to.
One is how parents or how adults in general respond to children.
Another one is how children respond to parents.
And I'll briefly talk about a few of these phenomena.
Small animals make distress calls.
Um,
they chirp the Myu they bleed or they cry.
This,
the governing of a distress call is actually an extremely delicate high wire act
for any young organism.
From an evolutionary point of view,
it has done a one hand be annoying enough to actually generate help to get
people to help you,
to feed you,
to pick you up,
to take you and put them next to you.
On the other hand,
it can't be so annoying that the people around you kill you.
And so it's complicated.
But from your point of view,
you're wired up to respond to them.
Um,
that sound is at very minimum,
extremely annoying.
Um,
and it's,
and it's more noise,
not only because of it's volume or pitch.
It's annoying because your brains are wired,
upset at that baby cry is going to drive you up the wall.
Um,
on a more positive side,
babies are cute.
Um,
I got this from Google images typing in cute baby,
getting rid of the porn and coming onto that,
oh no playboy anyway.
Is that,
um,
and um,
and do not be tempted to say,
isn't it wonderful that the way nature works is that babies are cute,
otherwise we would have killed him.
That's not the right story if,
if babies are not human,
babies are not sort of metaphysically cue.
If martians came down,
he Wednesday OCU baby rather there,
Hugh,
because of how our brains are wired up.
They're cute because there's certain cues,
um,
that,
that correspond to the way our brains work.
Um,
and in fact there's a Alizar for all mammals.
So babies have these big protruding foreheads.
I'm an upturn,
a little nose,
chubby cheeks and big eyes.
Those are the ingredients for cute.
Stephen Jay Gould has a wonderful essay where he discussed this looking at the
evolution and Mickey Mouse from Walt Disney herder make email,
starts off as an ugly little rodents.
Over time he gets cuter and cuter and cuter as the artist's converge on more and
more baby like features.
Um,
studies of adults show what's known as a baby face bias.
This is not unique to United States.
The same studies have been done.
Um,
in a,
in Asia you find a baby face and an adult Leonardo DiCaprio to be particularly,
um,
naive,
helpless kind and warm.
Um,
and in mock trials people have,
baby faces are more likely to be found innocent and people like Ben Affleck who
do not have.
Now.
Now one question which is going to come up for an entire lecture later on is who
is sexier,
the baby face man or testosterone than here.
Um,
and I'm going to ask actually for a vote because when returned to this,
I do not,
I only want the men to vote.
Please.
Um,
who would go for and forget if he looks like an unhappy who would go for Affleck
hair.
Okay.
Who would go for Leonardo.
Um,
the women votes would actually be more complicated.
We will discuss when we get to lecture on sex.
Your choice.
We'll the pen on where are you are in a menstrual cycle.
Now,
so far,
so far we're talking about how babies respond to 'em.
We talking about our responses to babies.
What about babies responses to us?
Well,
there's a very old theory known as the cupboard theory proposed by the
behaviors.
BF Skinner,
which argues that baby's attachment to their parents is because the parent
provides food characteristically,
you know,
breast milk but could be food from a bottle or whatever.
And because of operant conditioning,
the baby is driven towards,
uh,
the adult.
An alternative theory is that a Bowlby,
which is that they're drawn to their mother for comfort and social interaction
as well as fear of strangers.
To test this,
the psychologist Harlow performed a series of ingenious experiments with
nonhuman primates,
um,
distinguishing between
what he called wire mothers and cloth mothers.
And you'll see illustrations of this to follow.
Why are mothers are mothers that are built that they give food.
They have a little nipple attached and you can drink from it and give food to
the baby.
And that's the baby source of food clause.
Mothers don't give any food.
Um,
but they give warmth and comfort.
There was a while in the psychology department where one professor was known to
be extremely supportive to his students,
um,
but didn't really provide much warmth than he was known as the,
the cloth mother.
And another one was very productive in everything but provide no love.
And she was known as the wire mother.
But um,
but,
but anyway,
I'll show you the movies.
I have to warn you.
This third and final movie is an example of why this research is not currently
done.
Um,
but,
but it illustrates,
it illustrates an important scientific point.
I don't know him.
I think I'm
just more Google images.
Um,
I think I want to begin next class by wrapping up and explaining the Harlow's
studies more detail and what they tell us and then we'll move towards altruism
towards non non-kin.
I'll see you next week.